>> ♪ ♪
>> Laura: THIS IS FUN.
REPUBLICAN INVESTIGATORS IN
CONGRESS HAVE A NEW AND SLIGHTLY
TROUBLING QUESTION FOR THE FBI.
WHY DIDN'T THE BUREAU TELL THEM
THAT THE GUY WHO TRIGGERED THE
RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION HAD A
MULTI-MILLION DOLLARS CONNECTION
TO THE CLINTON FOUNDATION?
REPORTER ALLISON SPAN HAS BEEN
INVESTIGATING AUSTRALIAN
DIPLOMAT ALEXANDER DOWNER.
SHE JOINS US.
THIS IS LIKE A CAST OF
CHARACTERS.
LIKE A MYSTERY NOVEL.
TELL US ABOUT DOWNER AND HIS
CONNECTION TO ALL OF THIS
PAPADOPOULOS?
>> IN THE SUMMER OF 2016 DOWNER
CAME OUT WITH HIS EVIDENCE THAT
GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS.
HE HAD A DRINK WITH HIM IN A
LONDON BAR AND PAPADOPOULOS
REVEALED THAT RUSSIA HAD DIRT ON
HILLARY CLINTON.
HE GAVE THAT INFORMATION TO THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT AND THAT
LAUNCHED THE WHOLE RUSSIAN PROBE
INTO TRUMP'S RUSSIAN COLLUSION.
NOW WE FOUND OUT THAT DOWNER HAS
A TIE TO THE CLINTON FOUNDATION.
>> Laura: HE IS IN A BAR IN
LONDON AND RUNS INTO
PAPADOPOULOS.
THE CIRCUMSTANCES ARE
INTERESTING.
FAST FORWARD.
2 MONTHS AFTER HE SEES HIM IN
THAT BAR, AUSTRALIA BRINGS THIS
TO THE FBI.
TOOK TWO MONTHS.
THEN YOU FIND OUT THAT DOWNER'S
CONNECTION TO THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION IS?
>> SECURED A GRANT FOR $25
MILLION TO GO FOR AIDS
PREVENTION AND TREATMENT IN
ASIA.
>> Laura: THAT'S GREAT.
AIDS PREVENTION.
ANY QUESTION ABOUT HOW THAT
MONEY WAS USED?
>> THERE WAS AN AUDIT THAT WAS
CONDUCTED 3 YEARS LATER TO SEE
WHAT THAT PROJECT HAD ACHIEVED.
THEY DID ACHIEVE SOME GREAT
THINGS GETTING THOSE CHILDREN
THE ANTI-VIRAL DRUGS THEY
NEEDED.
BUT THERE WERE SOME QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE MONEY IN THAT CASE AND
WHETHER IT WAS HANDLED PROPERLY.
THE REPORT SAYS THAT IT WAS SO
MISHANDLED IT WAS DETRIMENTAL TO
THE PROJECT.
THEY WERE GIVEN A SCORE FOR 2
OUT OF 6 FOR HANDLING THE MONEY.
>> Laura: 2 OUT OF 6.
FOR THE CLINTONS THAT'S A HIGH
MARK IN ETHICES.
THIS IS FROM THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION AUDIT:
WAS WASN'T THIS REVEALED?
THAT'S A BIG GRANT WITH A
CONNECTION TO THE OPPOSITION
CANDIDATE DONALD TRUMP.
HE IS IN THE BAR AND MEETS
PAPADOPOULOS AND FUNNELS THE
INFORMATION.
HE IS NOT A MINOR FIGURE.
HE IS A WELL KNOWN LIBERAL
POLITICIAN IN AUSTRALIA WHO IS
BUDDIES WITH THE CLINTONS?
>> THAT'S WHAT CONGRESS IS
ASKING.
WE BROUGHT THIS TO THE
CONGRESSAL COMMITTEES.
THE FBI DID NOT DISCLOSE THIS
INFORMATION TO THEM.
>> Laura: THAT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
>> JORDAN WANTS A SECOND SPECIAL
COUNSEL BECAUSE THE FBI CAN'T
INVESTIGATE THEMSELVES.
>> Laura: FIRST THE DOSSIER
FUNDED BY HILLARY CLINTON AND
THE DNC.
THAT WAS NOT REVEALED TO THE
FISA JUDGE.
NOW YOU HAVE THIS.
>> THERE ARE ACTUALLY FOUR
PIECES OF INFORMATION.
THE DOSSIER WAS FUNDED BY THE
DNC AND CLINTON.
AND THE FISA APPLICATION WAS
WRITTEN BY MICHAEL.
>> Laura: THAT WAS REALLY FAST.
>> IT'S VERY COMPLICATED.
WE HAVE FOUR INSTANCES.
ALL OF THE INFORMATION CAME FROM
THE CLINTONS.
>> Laura: SAM NUNBERG WHO WORKED
FOR THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN FOR 5
SECONDS.
HE IS REFUSEING TO SPEAK TO
MUELLER.
HE WAS ON CNN EARLIER TONIGHT.
I AM SORRY, THIS IS TOO FUNNY
NOT TO PLAY TO YOU.
LET'S WATCH.
>> SAM, I HAVE TO ASK YOU ONE
OTHER THING.
>> YES, MA'AM.
>> IT'S AWKWARD.
YOU ARE SITTING VERY CLOSE TO
ME.
WE TALKED ABOUT WHAT PEOPLE IN
THE WHITE HOUSE SAID ABOUT YOU,
WHETHER YOU WERE DRINKING OR ON
DRUGS.
TALKING TO YOU, I HAVE SMELLED
ALCOHOL ON YOUR BREATH.
>> I HAVE NOT HAD A DRINK.
NO.
>> BECAUSE IT IS THE TALK OUT.
THERE I KNOW IT'S AWKWARD.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> MY ANSWER IS NO.
>> Laura: THOUGHTS?
>> THAT WAS PAINFUL TO WATCH.
>> Laura: I DON'T KNOW HIM AT